l'alerté très sévère elle est lancée par
l' oms tout doit être fait pour contenir
l'épidémie de grippe du poulet qui sévit
en asie
depuis quelques jours le virus attaque
en effet à l'homme et les scientifiques
n'hésite pas à faire la comparaison avec
la grippe espagnole
stéphane lippert l'hôpital de sukhothai
à l'ouest de la thaïlande
cet enfant avait 7 ans il est la
deuxième victime en deux jours de la
grippe du poulet
la veille déjà un enfant de 6 ans avait
succombé à cette maladie
plongeant sa famille et tout le pays
dans le désarroi
les médecins ont fait de leur mieux mais
les enfants sont plus fragiles face à
cette maladie car leur système
immunitaire est plus faible
nous ne savons pas quoi faire les
médecins ont fait tout leur possible
demeure en thaïlande six morts au
vietnam
les chiffres ne sont pas encore alarmant
mais les spécialistes sont très inquiets
jamais ils n'ont vu une épidémie se
répandre aussi rapidement depuis son
apparition il ya un mois en corée du sud
elle s'est propagée dans 9 pays d'asie
après le pakistan
hier le laos et surtout la chine ont
reconnu à leur tour être touchés
aujourd'hui pour l'instant celle lips et
transmises de l'animal à l'homme mais l'
oms redoute maintenant des transmission
directe entre humains si le virus se
combiner avec la grippe humaine qui se
dirige en ce moment vers l'asie les
conséquences pourraient être terribles
il y a toujours le risque que ce genre
d'épidémie devienne une sérieuse
pandémie mondiale qui n'impliquerait pas
seulement des centaines mais des
millions de personnes dans le monde
l'abattage de 20 millions de poulets
dans toute l'asie n'a pas suffi à
freiner l'épidémie
l'om est réclame maintenant une aide
internationale aucun vaccin ne sera
disponible avant l'hiver prochain pour
se prémunir
l'union européenne a décidé la semaine
dernière l'embargo sur les importations
de volailles thaïlandaise